sea gx igual a la integral definida de 0
a x df de tdt cual es la justificación
con base en el cálculo teniendo en
cuenta que es cóncava hacia arriba en el
intervalo abierto de 5 a 10 antes de ver
a qué nos referimos con cóncava hacia
arriba vamos a asegurarnos de comprender
la relación deje de x una forma de
comprender esta relación es obteniendo
la derivada en ambos lados de la
igualdad nos queda que g prima de x es
igual a fx la razón por la que tenemos
esto es para mostrar la variable t esto
es una función de x x es el límite
superior de la integral definida usamos
la variable t porque sería raro el tener
una integral con respecto a x cuyo
intervalo superior también fuera x
esto podría confundirnos es por eso que
ponemos otra variable puede ser t puede
ser zeta puede ser alfa puede ser
cualquier variable que queramos pero
esto sigue siendo una función de x al
calcular la derivada en ambos lados de
la igualdad
vemos que la función f que se muestra en
esta gráfica
ejes x por lo que esta es fx si el eje
fuera tendríamos ft
esta es la gráfica de f que también
podemos ver como la gráfica de g prima
si tenemos el eje x esta será g prima de
x nos interesa el intervalo abierto de 5
a 10 aquí tenemos la gráfica de la
derivada g prima y queremos encontrar
una justificación con base en el cálculo
usando esta gráfica que nos permita
saber si se es cóncava hacia arriba que
significa que sea cóncava hacia arriba
significa que la pendiente de la recta
tangente se incrementa
y otra forma de pensar en esto es que si
la derivada se está incrementando en el
intervalo la función es cóncava hacia
arriba en ese intervalo aquí tenemos la
gráfica de la derivada y vemos que se
incrementa en este intervalo por lo que
nuestra justificación con base en el
cálculo es que f que es g prima en este
intervalo se incrementa la derivada se
incrementa en ese intervalo y por lo
tanto las funciones cóncava hacia arriba
en ese intervalo
la segunda opción dice f es positiva en
el intervalo abierto de 5 a 10 esta no
es una justificación suficiente ya que
si la derivada es positiva significa que
nuestra función original se está
incrementando pero no nos dice que la
función original es cóncava hacia arriba
la tercera opción dice
efe es cóncava hacia arriba en el
intervalo abierto de 5 a 10 el que la
derivada sea cóncava hacia arriba no
significa que la función original
también sea cóncava hacia arriba de
hecho podemos tener una situación como
ésta en donde la derivada es cóncava
hacia arriba en ese intervalo
en gran parte de ese intervalo esta es
la función f
prima la función está disminuyendo
durante gran parte de ese intervalo de
hecho en esta parte nuestra función será
cóncava hacia abajo la última opción
dice la gráfica de g tiene forma de un
en el intervalo abierto de 5 a 10 si
tuviéramos la gráfica de g
esta sería una justificación válida pero
no sería una justificación con base en
el cálculo resolvamos otro problema
tenemos la misma configuración seage x
igual a la integral definida de 0 a x de
f dt cuál es la justificación con base
en el cálculo tomando en cuenta que g
tiene un mínimo relativo en x igual a 8
nuevamente la gráfica efe de aquí es
igual a la derivada de g y si tenemos la
gráfica de la derivada como podemos
saber si hay un mínimo relativo en la
función original alrededor de x igual a
8 el hecho de que la derivada cruza por
este punto cuando x es igual a 8 quiere
decir que la pendiente de la recta
tangente de g
punto es igual a 0 pero eso no quiere
decir que tengamos un punto mínimo
relativo aquí para poder tener un punto
mínimo relativo nuestra derivada tiene
que pasar de ser negativa a positiva
porque nos sirve esto piensen que si
nuestra derivada pasa de ser positiva a
negativa significa que la función
original pasa de disminuir a
incrementarse y si hace esto tendremos
un mínimo relativo en este punto veamos
cuál opción describe esto la primera
opción no es suficiente para indicar que
tenemos un mínimo relativo la tercera
opción dice
efe es negativa antes de x igual a 8 y
positiva después de x igual a 8 esto
describe exactamente lo que analizamos
esta opción es correcta veamos las otras
opciones
la segunda opción dice efe es cóncava
hacia arriba alrededor de x igual a 6 el
que x sea igual a 6 no tiene que ver con
que x sea igual a 8 descartamos esta
opción la última opción dice existe un
intervalo en la gráfica de g alrededor
de x igual a 8 donde g de 8 es el valor
pequeño esta sería una justificación
para tener un mínimo relativo pero no es
basada en el cálculo por eso la
descartamos hagamos otro problema
tenemos la misma configuración aunque
diferentes efe que en la gráfica sea gx
igual a la integral definida de 0 a x de
ft dt cuál es la justificación con base
en el cálculo tomando en cuenta que g es
positiva en el intervalo cerrado de 7 a
12 señalamos el intervalo que nos
interesa aquí vamos a analizar con más
detalle qué significa tener esta
integral de 0 a x si pensamos en lo que
sucede cuando x es igual a 7 que es lo
mismo que decir que g de 7 es igual a la
integral definida de 0 a 7 df de tdt
imaginemos que este eje este esta
variable t sólo nos sirve para no
confundirnos con la variable x del
límite superior pero realmente nos
referimos a esta área de aquí y ya que
de 0 a 7 la función está por arriba del
eje tendremos un área positiva si vemos
el intervalo de 7 a 12 no agregamos nada
al área anterior pero tampoco quitamos
nada a dicha área así que de x igual a 7
a x igual a 12 la integral conservará el
mismo valor positivo no le agregamos
valor así que ge de 12 es igual a g de 7
pues no agregamos ni quitamos nada a
esta área veamos cuáles son las opciones
que coinciden la primera opción para
cualquier valor de x en el intervalo
cerrado de 7 a 12
el valor de fx es 0 vemos en la gráfica
que esto es verdadero pero no significa
que sea positivo antes de este punto
nuestra función podría hacer algo así
por lo que tendríamos un área negativa
hasta este punto y estos también serían
valores negativos descartamos esta
opción
la segunda opción dice para cualquier
valor de x en el intervalo cerrado de 7
a 12 el valor de g de x es positivo esto
es verdadero y me gusta esta opción
veamos las otras opciones la tercera
opción dice efe es positiva en el
intervalo cerrado de 0 a 7 y no negativa
en el intervalo cerrado de 7 a 12
también me gusta esta opción y voy a
descartar la opción anterior porque no
se refiere a la derivada por lo que no
es una justificación con base en el
cálculo esta tercera opción describe
justo el razonamiento que hicimos
efe es positiva de 0 a 7 por lo que
tenemos un área positiva y no es
negativa en el resto del intervalo por
lo que se mantendrá positiva en todo
este intervalo elegimos esta opción la
cuarta opción dice
efe no es cóncava hacia arriba ni
cóncava hacia abajo en el intervalo
cerrado de 7 a 12 esto no nos ayuda con
la afirmación de que g es positiva en el
intervalo cerrado de 7 a 12 descartamos
esta opción y con esto terminamos